[Music]
wake up with the sun in the morning go
to sleep
for the model train Enthusiast we lord
over a world where the neighbors are
always kind their lovers always end up
together Allison every memory I cherish
as you and I love you
and the trains always take you to the
far-off places you've always wore you'd
go
and life of course nothing is nearly as
neat and tidy
[Music]
aren't you engaged to Nathan Adams I was
yeah I heard what happened to you by
accident the woman that died was about
to be my sister-in-law
[Music]
hi Dan
[Music]
I'm worried about you I want my life
back I want my child back
oh
I need help I know
[Music]
Allison Don't Run Away now because of me
there are thousands of meetings I'll
find another one well somehow you found
your way to this one
come on
lately after much of my life has been
out of control I just called my
granddaughter having sex with a boy who
looked like a man hey Belinda I found
this fool in bed with my Ryan she said
she was 18 online you're a [ __ ] boy he's
a [ __ ] boy that's what the kids call
them get out of our neighborhood [ __ ]
boy okay okay
what the hell did you do to your hair
it's makeover Monday it's Friday oh
this is incredible my wife used to hang
out with me down there she liked the
whistle
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know how to do this it takes
work
I got one of those audio books and how
to talk to a team how's that working out
I am so not going to talk about sex with
my grandfather really because I just
love this [ __ ] I'm in way over my head
I was thinking if we found like a craft
that we like we could be on Shark Tank
we'll be like hey sharks
I knew you would like that idea